hi oh i'm kermit the frog and
yeah i mean naturally i'm definitely not
kermit the frog i'm miss vicki
that's right and we are here to do the
wired auto complete interview
so hit it
on a correct no interview complete
auto complete i think this whole thing
needs to be auto completed for us
yeah i know
here we go this is under this section
who
kermit the frog all right let's dance
and the first question is
yeah who's kermit the frog
uh me me me uh yeah he's an amphibian
named kermit okay on to the next one who
are kermit the frog parents
okay uh who are my parents are ma and
paw frog
my ma i called her ma and my pie i
called him paw
huh it's fascinating who
is kermit the frog friends
oh uh gee i've got a lot of them i mean
all them up it's uh
fozzie and gonzo
yeah i'm miss big and miss begin but of
course miss biggie yes
you are you saved the best for last
right that is right
who is kermit the frog
nephew i know that one do you want to
answer it you can answer it
you know his name is robin and he's
adorable
he's like a more handsome looking
version of his uncle
okay here we go miss piggy ready ready
what
is miss piggy's last name
it's not the obvious answer
that is what i'm going to say what's the
obvious answer it's not
piggy oh i have to have a little mystery
okay uh-huh uh yes yes right
okay next question then uh what is miss
piggy's
first name it's miss piggy
that miss piggy yeah i'd shorten it to
just piggy but when you've spent all the
time and effort that i have
creating a high-end brand like miss
piggy
you don't change it all right we'll take
that i am still not telling you my last
name no no no that's that's fine uh what
is miss piggy's favorite color
ooh i'd say it's a toss up uh between
pink and gold no no silver and platinum
what exact color would you say diamonds
are
what does miss piggy sound like oh
well i would say that i sound
like angels singing on high
when i'm happy at least if i'm unhappy i
sound like this
just a natural reaction a gut reaction
from me i'm sorry about that i had that
duck
all right next question what does miss
piggy call kermit
the frog well that depends if i'm
happy i might call him kermie
um if i'm unhappy i might call him frog
and if i'm really unhappy
i just let this do the talking
okay it's time for me to ask you some
questions
what is kermit the frog's full
name oh my full name that is easy
it is you're ready for it kermit
the frog yeah kermit the frog that's my
name you know a funny story
uh when i was a tadpole they called me
kermit the tadpole but then i dropped my
tail
and when i became a frog then my name
became kermit the frog so
that's yeah that's the story and it's
all true changed her name
we did yeah it's a big day in a frog's
life
what instrument does kermit the frog
play i play the banjo yeah
i play the banjo but you know in a pinch
i can also play the zither
the what the zither it's another
the heck is a zether what was kermit the
frog's
original color you were a different
color
no no green green i mean
i've
green frogs in my family only come in
one color even when we're tadpoles just
green
all right the answer is green don't get
mad
i'm not mad i'm just being emphatic
about it it's not even my question
what is kermit the frog's age
oh well um you know i i i've been around
since around you know 1955 but uh
but in frog years i'm only in my mid-20s
yeah me too
me too this section is called miss piggy
here we go who is miss piggy
yeah i got a question who's been living
under a rock their entire life
hmm good grief right that's just a
question
yeah who knows what she wants
and knows how to get that's who i am
yeah where did miss piggy meet kermit
i know this one because you were there
mm-hmm we
originally met at the bougain county
fair
that's right where i had just won
a beauty pageant and then
you decided that i was
going to be a big star on the muppet
show
well you know i mean that is where you
kind of joined us i mean you kind of i
mean
i could just tell by the look in your
eyes that you wanted
moi in your life for the rest of your
life
okay all right you know memory is a
funny thing we we all have our own
memories
right okay next question why does miss
piggy
always wear gloves oh well that's
actually a good question
when i started out i was a hand
model and they paid me in gloves yeah
and i'm still working my way through
them
what miss piggy says
seriously yeah what miss piggy says what
miss piggy says
i guess i want to know what you're
saying i don't know miss piggy says
bonjour miss piggy says moi
hm mr speaker says hi yeah
like catchphrases those are like your
catchphrases not catch phrases
they're just things i say okay this is
the kermit the frog and miss piggy
section
why don't you uh why don't you take the
first one okay kermit
the frog and miss piggy
baby yeah baby i mean
we need to get married no no no no no no
look look look i know what it is i know
what it is
in our movie the muppets take manhattan
we filmed a flashback
to when we were babies and that's what
that's referring to yeah that's what
that's about
yes i was so cute then
and i just keep getting cuter don't i
came it
i'm gonna read the next question uh it's
uh
kermit the frog and miss piggy dropped
the mic oh
oh yeah yeah yeah you remember that
piggy we had a lot of fun doing drop the
mic didn't we
yeah you were too nice though well i was
too nice
well i i can't help it that's my style
kermit
the frog and miss piggy
[Music]
wedding
actually you know that that that well
you see
in the muppet state manhattan our film
we we
we had a big wedding scene and uh but
you know it was all a fantasy it was
just hollywood magic you know it was
just uh written in a sweatshirt
magic nonetheless wouldn't you say
yeah it was it was a nice there was a
nice scene
performed by two actors
sometimes lovers okay here's another one
kermit the frog and miss piggy singing
rainbow connection oh well that's really
more your song isn't it oh yeah yeah it
is i think i mean of course
i make it better whenever i sing it with
you but
it's still it's i'll let you have that
one okay
thank you i i i appreciate that
moving on what does kermit
the frog say about being
green oh well it's not easy
that's what i say about being green it's
not easy
and uh for further details just see the
song be in green
it covers it that's a nice song oh thank
you especially when ray charles sings it
ah it's so good so good
what does kermit the frog meme
mean oh oh yeah i mean i get this all
the time
what do you know that the t yeah yeah
with the t yeah i'm not sure what that
means but uh
you know it's not in my business oh i
like this one what
is a round kermit the frog's
neck well yeah what the heck is that
kermit
and that's my collar yeah collar yeah
it's my collar yeah
yeah that is something you put on in the
morning
yeah yeah yeah i feel naked without it
but uh
i i also feel naked with it but uh as we
say around the swamp if you're not gonna
wear pants wear a collar
okay what color are
kermit the frog's eyes i know this
one oh okay yeah let's see here look
look at there
see that wait a minute they're they're
black and white
they are black and white yeah they're
black and white i thought they were
brown
what oh they're not brown they're black
and white i could have sworn they were
brown
i hope you learned something about us
today but not too much
i want to stay mysterious right thank
you wired
thank you